oh my goodness i feel so crazy in a
parking lot angelica where'd you
put it i just spent way too much money
on air tags and air attack accessories
and since apple didn't send us these i
can give you my honest thoughts
on if they are actually worth it and
test out things that others haven't
mentioned
such as how loud the speaker is and how
long it takes
to find your lost item once you put it
into that lost mode along with that
we'll see
which accessories are actually worth it
and we're actually going to do a
teardown
on one of these air tags i also bought a
bunch of much cheaper
third-party air tag accessories to
compare to the oem ones to see if you
should save yourself some money
and along with that upcoming video we're
gonna do a comparison against the tile
pro
testing out real world things such as
the range the speakers and much more so
if you guys want to see those videos
click that subscribe button down below
and you guys can help us reach our goal
of 1 million subscribers before the end
of the year
we would highly appreciate it let's go
ahead and get these accessories and
other air
tags out of the way and open up our
first four pack
bam there we have it a four pack of air
tags
don't need the really the instructions
let's go ahead and pull one of these out
i have to say that this thing actually
weighs a fair bit more than i expected
it has some heft to it
and it also is thicker kind of in your
hand
than i thought it definitely isn't super
slim quality wise it definitely feels
nice
let's pull this tab out i don't know if
you guys could hear that little
notification that means the battery's
connected
bam before i even set it down air tag
shows up right here let's hit connect
and let's do how about for this one
we'll do keys we'll keep that one simple
and bam we are all done right there i
gotta say the setup was
incredibly easy and simple you really
can't get any easier than that
now this is the menu in the find my app
for this ear tag
and we have the option to find it or
play sound let's go ahead and press
the play sound option
angelica what do you think about the
loudness pretty good actually you think
it's pretty good i thought it would be a
little bit louder than this
because i'm sitting right next to it you
guys probably pick it up there in the
mic
i guess we'll have to see in the real
world you know once we lose
something how the sound is if it's
enough to find it of course we also have
the find
option so it's going to connect here bam
oh that haptic feedback is cool this is
something you can't get over video
my phone is vibrating and as i get it
closer it gets stronger and stronger
kind of like passing off
audio to a home pod and look how fast
this responds
as soon as i get closer it actually
knows how far away it is
and then of course it's actually
tracking from the top here so it says
here
start moving away and bam you literally
get that really quick readout
let me go hide this under the cushion
and we'll see how loud it is if i can
actually hear it
all right let's hit that sound
you know what that's actually really
weird that sounds almost as loud as it
was here on the table
and the frequencies kind of change like
it's a different tone so i wonder if
they did that on purpose so yeah i could
definitely hear
where it's at angelica can you go put it
into the other room let's hit play once
again
and now it's about 25 feet or so away in
a different room with that door closed
let's listen
wow okay so that is actually almost as
loud as it was here on the table
and under the couch cushion just about
10 feet away
that is actually quite surprising that i
could still hear it so
i was doubting it at first but maybe
it's just that frequency now if you're
somebody with an older iphone you will
have to use this
sound mode because you won't have access
to the find feature
so let's go ahead and play that sound
again and i'm going to try to find
where angelica hid it i gotta say guys
please excuse our mess our office is not
in good shape right now
let's hit play sound once again
okay i hear it is it in there
i don't know i want to find i want to
use the find my feature it's not in here
right
oh it is all right i hear it down here
okay in the bag it's kind of a bummer
how quickly that sound stops playing
i know it's here somewhere oh all right
i got it
so i was able to find it but i'm sure
that would be much easier
if we just use the fine feature let's
just try that again
maxim's keys connection's weak bam three
feet
oh the vibration is kicking in there you
go so yeah if you do have an iphone
12 or an iphone 11 then you'll actually
be able to use this function
and it will be much easier now before we
test out the lost mode and see
how long it takes for this air attack to
be found when angelica's gonna go
and hide it for a few blocks away first
let's take a look at some of these
accessories and see
which one of these are actually worth it
so the only key
ring that apple sells is this leather
one they don't sell a silicon one and
this one costs
35 dollars so it's actually more
expensive than the actual air tag
the quality is nice i like that this key
ring is very
flat and this thing is super super
secure
leather quality feels like normal apple
leather let's go ahead and open this up
and pop in our ear tag and as you guys
can see both sides are
open so you probably will end up
scratching up aluminum part right here
and probably the glossy white as well i
do have one third-party option
that is inexpensive actually everything
is covered so that might be
something that's going to be good and as
far as these loops um these are made for
luggage this costs 39 bucks so it's
actually a little bit more expensive
and it looks like it's basically the
same let's go ahead and pop
one of these air tags in here since i
have so many of these now
and then we're just gonna loop it
through pretend it's on a backpack or
something or your luggage
they do have a less expensive version
let's see if it's worth saving
that 10 bucks all right wow actually
this doesn't really feel like they're
cases
it feels uh less grippy like less stuff
is gonna stick to it which is good
and then on the inside they have this
kind of a little bit of a felt
material or something like that
definitely a little bit nicer quality
than i expected
from this and then we have these belkin
accessories which are the only third
party ones that apple sells on their
website these are
a lot less expensive you guys can see 13
bucks
so here's that uh actual holder and then
the key ring
all right nice this is another one that
is kind of flat not completely rounded
let's see if it's as thin as apples yeah
pretty much as thin
but it's actually a little bit smaller
in diameter check that out you can't
really tell
these kind of things from the website
which is why i wanted to do this
the way you insert the air tag here you
literally just twist that
plop it in let's align this i think
there should be a little alignment spot
here yep
right there bam and now it is closed now
i have to say
this plastic definitely feels a lot
cheaper
and less premium than the leather and
then the silicone one right here
look how much closer it is to the actual
key ring
you know what i just realized something
with apple's key ring
you actually have to keep the leather
with this included
ring right up here because if you take
that off i went ahead and grabbed my
keys
and you just attach it to the one you're
already using or you swap your keys to
this one
all your keys are going to be the
opposite direction to your air tag
holder so you have to actually attach
this whole piece
onto your keys making it quite a bit
longer
whereas with the belkin bam look at that
it actually lines up
exactly like my keys are same
orientation and look how little space
that takes up instead of having
something
that will have to hang down way lower
and then for the very last one we have
belkin's loop once again this feels
cheap but i don't know if that matters
to you guys you guys let me know down
below
if you care about it feeling cheap or
not i do think this white one
does look a little bit nicer and let me
spin that apple logo
and then with this you can just grab the
loop through here and this part of it
actually feels pretty
high quality the actual uh string here
so that is
belkin's version of apple's loop
um and you could just say similar thing
just attach it to
whatever you want i thought i was going
to like the leather more so than
belkin's cheaper options
but now that i'm seeing these in person
and i'm seeing how this looks and how
this attaches and it's a lot more
streamlined
and then of course the keychain where
you don't have to use that included ring
and you can get it just really close to
your keys i think that i actually like
belkin's option better but of course we
do have a bunch of other alternatives
that we're going to make a video on so
make sure you guys enable those
notifications
all right guys and now what i am
personally most excited for
and that is seeing how long it takes me
to find these keys when i put it into
lost mode
how well does apple's network actually
work so angelica i'm gonna trust you
with my keys i'm going to keep my actual
car key because i need it
and i'm going to give you my house keys
the office keys everything so you take
this
here you go go ahead and hide it
somewhere
out there and hopefully we find these so
i'll be back with you in just a second
let's activate that loss mode
and uh let's wait let's start a timer
man
i cannot believe how long i've been
waiting so far and it still hasn't
found it oh what is that i just saw
direction
change no notification but the
directions just showed up
uh looks like 0.4 of a mile three minute
drive
um that took let's see 15 minutes and 29
seconds 15 and a half minutes
all right well let's go ahead and find
it all right let's attach this and let's
go find my keys i really hope
nobody took them one thing i just popped
into my mind is
i wonder how often the air tag when it's
away from you
actually pings signals to other iphones
it can't be every second
plus the battery will drain super
quickly so it's showing that we're about
a hundred feet away
in that the air tag is somewhere in the
intersection but i think we could
probably just pull over here somewhere
and then attempt to
connect to it and this would actually be
a good range test
all right we have the fine nearby option
let's go ahead and hit that
and let's go outside and try to find it
so it's saying that it's searching for a
signal
try moving to a different location
alright so this way doesn't seem to be
working
i guess we'll just have to turn around
and go the other way and my battery
is about to die come on here tags come
on
you can do it you can do it i feel like
somebody from those commercials the old
verizon ones
the can you hear me walking around with
my phone trying to get reception
uh but so far we're not having much luck
oh oh
okay okay we got something 37 feet i
just
i had a little thing saying signals weak
on the screen okay now which way do i go
41 um
still 41 nope signal's going away signal
is weak
i feel so crazy in a parking lot oh no
signal went away so let's go this way
and there's a drive through here
angelica where'd you put it maybe it's
across the street over there
oh my goodness okay oh oh okay 13 feet
maybe i shouldn't be moving so fast to
your right okay
oh there we go maybe i should have stood
there for a second because now it's
actually showing me the full animation
and the arrow and the haptics okay oh
geez
is it here okay is it in the bush here
okay
oh my goodness this is okay should i
just do the sound function now okay
let's do the sound
okay oh
why did it say like four feet that way
all right now i can see it yeah so
that's why we do have a speaker built
into the air tags that was way easier
all right guys we are back in the office
my keys are safely recovered and i want
to say that i did end up looking it up
i couldn't find any info on the air tags
but for tile they ping every 15
minutes so if you do put it into lost
mode you have to wait at least
that long in order to find it you can't
expect to find it in five minutes
like i did you know when i first started
playing with these air tags and now
for our final little bit of this video
let's get out our ifixit kit
and let's see what is inside of these
air tags push down they're supposed to
twist it
bam that was actually really easy and
this is actually really nice
the machining even the bottom we have a
cr2032
battery this should last about a year
you can get i believe a four pack for
about five bucks
or a 100 pack yes i said 100
for about 16 17 so overall it's quick
and easy to replace once a year
and very inexpensive let's go ahead and
pop that battery out
oh wow okay this thing is actually
really really lightweight
and here we're not seeing much we have a
couple pins there
uh one in the bottom and two right there
for the battery
and other than that i don't see any
screws or anything else
so all the electronics should be inside
of here
let's go ahead and see if we can open
there's a seam right here
hopefully i don't break this thing we'll
try
to not break it but i guess if it breaks
it might be worth the sacrifice
just to show this off to you guys i
would say don't do this at home
there's no need to do it oh there you go
wow that popped off
very easily and there we go there is the
inside
of your air tag we have a small little
motherboard
a few different chips and i wonder where
the speaker
is that's kind of what i wanted to see
i'm not seeing anything though
unless that center you see a little coil
right there
i had that must be what this is this
must be one part of the speaker and that
is the other part
and that kind of holds it together with
the magnet of course you need a magnet
four speakers
and there's the pins right there they
just actually pass through this cap so
as far as electronics there's barely
anything in here it's very
very lightweight very small but it
allows this product to work properly
very cool and now let's go ahead and see
if i broke this thing or if it still
works
let's pop our battery in here oh i heard
that sound
that's good news and we didn't break it
let's twist this down
hey we have air tag that works we didn't
break it
and now you just pop it right back into
your little accessory holder
and you're good to go so there you guys
go that is my first
in-depth testing of the air tags
hopefully that was
entertaining and informative as well if
you guys enjoyed it click that like
button and if you guys want to see more
videos
such as the comparison against tile and
possibly even the samsung tracker
and our air tags accessory video click
that circle above to subscribe and that
will help us reach a million subscribers
by the end of this year that would be
amazing
and check out one of those great videos
right over there that's been max and
i'll see you in the next video